So welcome here into the, in the studio. It's good to have you here.
It's a, it's a pleasure. I'm a little hung over a little gay, but uh,
just glad to be here with you, sister.
I appreciate you saying that. I'm very happy to be here with you too.
It's hurting my erection, but, uh, yeah,
this is great fan of the gals, uh, which is weird because when I was a kid,
I hated girls. When I was like six years old. I thought girls were gross.
I thought they were dumb. I know you're allowed to hate girls as a kid,
but that's why the only group a kids allowed to hate,
because if I was a six year old, that hated Puerto Rican's.
That would be weird, you know? But I was like, Hey mom, I hate Puerto Rican.
She would never say, Oh, you'll like them one day.
Well,
one thing that I've been able to kind of pick up as you do have that old self
deprecating humor, which I do enjoy in a comedian, hate myself.
I'm always drawn to people that hate me, I guess,
because we have so much in common, but I'm not good with the small talk,
you know, two things I can't do small talk and eye contact. How sad is that?
You know,
I basically have all the traits of a serial killer just without the ambition.
I'm working on it though. I'm working on it. You know, people are saying to me,
Mark, gotta be more confident. And they say, Mark, gotta be yourself. I'm like,
wow. Yeah,
I've been following it up in the green room. And uh.
Yeah.
A little smaller green room. Exactly. We call it. Hotboxing
really soaking it all in.
Cause it's the smell of your own forks for some reason is enjoyable.
If you forwarded it to be weird. But if I fart, I enjoy, I don't know.
Guy thing you would hear,
no woman would ever say something like that.
No, you guys are more of a, maybe a query thing. Oh my gosh. All right. Hey,
any Puerto Rican's here, right?
[inaudible] Puerto Rican's good people. Good people. A very passionate people,
a lot of knives, but passionate. Very fast. Hey, I'm just telling jokes.
I'm a comedian look, look, I live in New York city. All right. If I was racist,
I would be exhausted. So you grew up in new Orleans.
Oh yeah. Good times. Weird city. I always see new Orleans, great place to visit.
Not a great place to grow up. It's kind of like a dad who sells drugs,
but doesn't hug you. You know what I mean? You get the fun stuff,
but you don't get a ride to school.
I never think of it like that.
She works at a gay bar, so I'll go there from time to time, get a free drink.
Maybe a compliment.
My guy friends are blown away by this. They're like, dude, you go to gay bars.
That is weird. If some gay guy ever hit on me,
I don't know what I would do.
How about you just not have sex?
Pretty easy, sir. How do you feel about gay marriage getting past
that gay porn? Good Lord. You're a, you're a big fan.
Ma'am how do you feel about gay marriage getting past
bigots? I'm not racist. I look at racism the same way I look at Nickelback.
Yeah. It's fun to joke about, but uh, you never want to see.
[Inaudible].
So, but we're big. I mean you're young.
So getting into this business and getting into this business
and um.
35, 35, not that young, but uh, you know, not on the Viagra yet.
Or.
Am I, who knows? I like to snort it.
I think my weirdness is hurt me with the, with the gales.
I'm seeing somebody now, but, uh, boy, I was a bad dater. I, uh,
I went on a blind date once. Right? When the girls saw me, she goes, Hey, I bet,
whatever really cute kids. I was like, all right, I bet we'd have great sex.
And she goes, Whoa, slow down. I was like,
I was like, slow down. You're nine months ahead of me. But Hey,
that's why I'm a comedian because I got to get love.
Somewhere. Oops. Sorry.
Is that a me too? All right.
I, uh, I drank too much. I, um, actually got, let,
go from a job for being drunk at work. Yeah. My boss called me and he goes,
get in here, Mark. It's clear. You're a high functioning alcoholic. I was like,
wow. How do you know? I was also high? I nor lady approached me.
Once she goes, Oh, I'm going to kidnap you. I was like, wow.
I could never say that to a woman. I sent it to a lady. She calls the police.
I would be curious to know what a woman can say. That would offend me like,
all right, I'm going to take you home drug.
You take advantage of you and film it. I'd be like, all right,
well at least let me pay for the Uber
I a single guy back on the scene. All right.
Prove it. Cat. Call us ladies. That'd be hilarious.
You know,
start yelling stuff at us that we don't want to hear stuff that would scare a
guy. You know, you walk past a group of girls at night when I was like, Hey,
I'll tell you, I love you on the first day. You're like, Holy hell.
That is terrifying. Yeah. Get us back. You know, you walk past a girl.
She's like, Hey, before we have sex, I'm gonna poke a hole in the condom.
This is a horrible, like I was on the subway resale.
I was watching interracial couple make-out. I was just staring at him
and the guy next to them caught me. He goes, what the hell?
I see you staring at them. What are you racist? I was like, what? Racist? No,
I'm a creep. What are you talking about? I'm hard.
You're going to be here. I, uh, I Ubered here. That was,
I had a real chatty driver. Oh,
I hate would it be nice if there was a small talk option on the app, you know,
but there isn't. So you got to really find your own way to quiet the guy.
I like to scare him and I he's like, Hey, I bought this traffic.
What do you think is causing this? I'm like probably the Jews. He's like,
all right, nice, quiet ride.
[Inaudible].